well new details in the officer-involved
shooting outside an elementary school
this morning
it happened in the southeast valley by
sandhill and twain
kristen drummond is live outside with
the latest details on this
kristin christian the shooting happened
before
nine this morning outside harris
elementary school here behind me
the campus was placed on a soft lockdown
which is normal
whenever there is police activity nearby
ccsd confirms that a ccsd police officer
was involved
in the shooting it happened when their
motorcycle unit was out here doing
enforcement
an officer pulled a driver over who
requested to speak to a supervisor
ccsd police say the supervisor was there
and approached the driver
at some point the driver decided to roll
up his window and drive away
knocking the supervisor to the ground
and causing his gun to go off
ccsd police say the shooting did not
seem though to
impact the school day it has absolutely
had no impact on education the kids
we've been inside the school several
times
kids have been going to and from class i
don't think most of the staff inside
don't even know what's going on out here
ccsd police are reviewing body camera
video and looking for the driver as well
as the car
which is a black nissan anyone with
information can call ccsd police the
numbers at the bottom of your screen at
or metro 702-799-5411 who are also
helping with the investigation
now ccsd police say the supervisor who
was knocked over was looked at
and is fine and they also suspect that
the driver
is well and is fine as well now this is
the
first officer involved shooting for the
department in about
five years reporting live in the east
valley kristin drummond 8 news now